hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay I couldn't
find another mouse so um I'm just gonna
hope and pray that that never happens
again cuz that was damn terrifying okay
all right
oh yeah follow the trail of blood I
don't care if it's brightly lit it's not
gonna last that way why is it brightly
lit in here in every other part of the
game comes like boom oh I kicked a trash
can it's like completely dark and now
that I think about why did my not white
why does my mouse only crap out when I'm
in battle why not you know when I'm
walking around here why doesn't my mouse
crap out then huh
why oh because it's in league with the
monsters boom no probably not
oh what a good door hey oh hey guy
hey what am i doing ah what the oh oh
what is that it's a baby oh oh sorry guy
Oh
his head is sploded your freaky baby oh
they're babies in test tubes that's
terrible
that is horrible oh man I think I need I
think I need the the assault rifle for
this see I got ammo don't use yo
oh wait what's the old fire on what's
what's the offer on this one that's it
it shoots sideways it's useless useless
okay I'll give you soda but because I've
been picking up some ammo oh that is
wrong why are they twitching oh yeah oh
ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you okay and that
took 25 bullets to kill one this assault
rifle might be grabbed Nick no no hey
hey yes no no no no die die
oh man sig is useless listen Ellie back
get outta here oh man
okay those things are just tough cuz I
took four shots but still four shops vs.
25 bullets I know I get him 25 at a time
apparently but still what's fair
oh man why were people having so many
babies on this ship how big is this ship
man oh ha ha ha wait is that are those
drawers of body parts that's awesome
fingers legs arms Wow cool
oh I hear a baby here baby I got my
super awesome
plasma cutter they could shoot into two
direction not one - all right what's
this
Irma alright alright I feel my Chi
picked up should be able to melt through
the barricade how did you know it's our
banter ignited you watching in all this
position I can hear something big moving
out there oh not big enough for me wait
what
no no wasn't there another room down
there that they've been going did I go
on that one I don't think I did I don't
think I did
so let me venture on down try to explore
the depths all back it is so brightly
lit in here it is almost cheerful how
bright it is again but I know that it's
just a clever ruse to disguise a
horrible nature oh yeah there are
there's more stuff good thing I get
money and more money I love money dollar
dollar bill y'all mo okay yup we got at
least they're giving me lots of pulse
right so we're gonna salt rifle ammo
so Rifle Pulse I don't know it pulses
bullets into their face that's what it
does not thumping I don't like it
wait wasn't there another door up here
yeah this door oh no I'm an idiot this
is where I came out door that's it check
it
sorry guys I'm I'm an idiot when it
comes to these games oh what's that
up not even a problem gone outta here
and recharge my maker
get out here oh I see it so you can owe
it so you can like cut their legs and
then they're all that's more useful than
I thought oh I don't trust you
yeah actually Wow I'm sorry for knocking
that cuz that's actually gonna be really
useful yeah I didn't need to get the
other gun who's going to take care of
everything
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and admit
getting the pulse rifle seems like a
waste
maybe if I upgrade it it'll be better so
I don't know oh no all right okay let's
see here store let's see what's in store
haha downloaded flame-throwing yeah that
seems like a good weapon
alright let me thank you I could sell
back the pulse rifle wouldn't be able to
that much velocity but I got all these
pulse rifle rounds um
I think there's anything that I need to
sell the line gun do I don't know I'm
not gonna waste my money right now when
I don't know what everything is cuz
maybe it'll tell me later when I'll need
to buy cuz right now I'm probably just
wasting it I feel like I wasted on this
is Seoul rifle I'm gonna use it just
because I don't want to feel like it
wasted it oh okay huh Oh what is that oh
oh oh dude oh God dude you don't look so
good you don't look so good dude I want
to stop doing that
Oh broham what happened to your chest
no wonder you killed yourself man that
problem all your intestines are oh oh oh
man yet another stasis feature I don't
want to hit the stasis recharge I want
to pick up the ammo there we go
okay obviously I don't need stasis packs
because their stasis recharge stations
everywhere but what what what where
where where where where
okay there's another bench did I get any
more um power thingies yeah I got one
okay what does this do capacity Wow um
raise damaged by the 10.1 wow you can
raise it by a whole four please I guess
there are a lot of bullets so that might
mean something but I think I'm going to
stick to the plasma cutter actually know
if every damage if every bullet is one
five points like it said five points
right if every bullet is five points and
it's got 50 bullets that is 250 points
of damage per clip as opposed to 12
times 12 which is 144 it's technically
most rifle should be better maybe huh
why not why not all right I increased
its capacity so now it's got five times
75 damaged which as you all know is 375
points of damage per clip so smart okay
Thank You mystery computer who knows
everything that I need to do get out get
out of here yeah I hear out of mouse hey
hey oh hey hey hey oh hey whoa
oh there we go now things are dying okay
maybe this month wasn't as big of waste
as I thought it was explodey barrel No
dad that took a little bit more you get
get it okay god I think that was a
member you Dom nope okay um here we go
oh hey bro bro but you don't look so
good
you're right there again guy I find
lasts just long enough for him to die
okay um hey paranoid okay
sorry bro couldn't save oh hey there we
go
okay now things are dying a little
better for the ESL right okay maybe it
was just the babies it's time time for
what is it party time don't trust me all
right mom see okay you just fall out
really that pathetic you just fell out
okay elevator it's right way straight up
okay yeah okay
bad guys infidels okay anyway I got to
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching as always I appreciate every
single one of you and I will see you in
the next part bye bye